mortal kombat is known for its dynamic
characters and elaborate mythology
engaged in a series of tournaments to
protect the fate of earth realm each
combatant brings with them a complex
backstory that ties into all the action
every fighter has an interesting
memorable look and set of powers but no
one on the roster is quite as iconic as
subzero and scorpion
this famous ninja duo has been
representing fire and ice since the
first groundbreaking game arrived in
arcades back in 1992
ever since they have been synonymous
with the mortal kombat series providing
a rivalry that is up there without a
batman and the joker
you simply cannot talk about mortal
kombat without taking a deep dive into
the bad blood between the two deadly
ninjas
if you haven't spent any time exploring
the mortal kombat mythology you may
wonder what started their feud and why
they have so much hatred for one another
this is sub-zero and scorpion's
relationship explained
it's hard to imagine that two fighters
who look so similar could hate each
other so much
after all moral combat co-creator john
tobias revealed that the original idea
behind these mortal enemies was to make
quote
a pallet swapped character to save
memory meaning that they have plenty in
common behind the scenes
tobias based sub-zero's ninja clan the
lin kuei on his readings about a band of
thieves in china that went by the same
name
leaning on historical context the
creators thought up a rival clan based
in japan known as the shirai ryuk
scorpion and sub-zero were given a
predator-prey dynamic early in
development and the rest is history
however as covered by the official
warner brothers uk website
the two ninjas rivalry goes beyond a
simple pallet swap
while the two belong to opposing clans
they are also bound by a deep desire for
revenge
which was spurred on by the evil
sorcerer quan chi at first
sub-zero and scorpion fought in a
gruesome battle where the latter was
killed along with his family and clan
quan chi brought scorpion back as a
skeletal creature allowing the fallen
warrior to seek revenge
scorpion slaughtered sub-zero whose
brother then donned the iconic blue and
black suit to avenge his slain sibling
the vicious cycle continued but it
wouldn't last forever
everything changed in mortal kombat 10
where the two settled their differences
at long last
sub-zero approached scorpion with a
peace offering but the shirairu master
remained skeptical
only when sub-zero proved his sincerity
by saving scorpion from frost did he
earn his former rival's attention
they then accessed footage revealing
that quan qi was behind their long feud
and from there a new chapter began
sub-zero confessed and i know to my
clan's complicity and the shirai reuse
extinction our history would be
different
after many years old wounds had finally
healed and the sworn enemies were able
to put their differences aside
in mortal kombat 11 players see sub-zero
trying to gather intel when he is
approached by an unmasked scorpion with
flesh on his skull
indeed he is no longer undead and
tensions rise when he pulls a blade on
his old enemy
and what may be one of the most shocking
moments in the series the two do not
engage in combat
in fact they speak calmly to one another
like old allies
at this point it's clear that they have
left the past behind and have started
fresh as comrades
one of the more peculiar aspects of
sub-zero in scorpion's relationship is
that it was muddled in the 1995 movie
not only did they show up as loyal and
cooperative servants of shang tsung but
they appear to have no autonomy
whatsoever
it's a head scratcher to see the two
make an entrance together fighting for
the same team
their master did acknowledge that they
are the deadliest of enemies who were
put under his spell but for all its
merits the movie missed out on a
critical piece of mk mythology
fortunately it seems as though the new
movie aimed to rectify this blunder as
sub-zero and scorpion are throwing fists
or
spears rather within the first seven
minutes of 2021's mortal kombat
in the reboot viewers are immediately
treated to the important story beats
that establish their deep hatred for one
another
it's a sharp contrast to the original
movie where these two staple characters
are essentially glossed over and killed
at the hands of luke kang and johnny
cage instead of each other
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite video game movies are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one